on this Mother's Day weekend one mom who
couldn't be prouder as her daughter is
honored with an award long dreamed about
the subject Brown liquors especially
whiskey which have enjoyed a big
resurgence in America in the last decade
one particular brand of it bottled in
bond is currently having its moment
bottled in bond is about as authentic as
it gets and the person at the forefront
of this wave took us on a tasting tour
we visited Tennessee just before social
distancing guidelines were put in place
for more than a century the water
flowing from this cascade spring in
central Tennessee has been the raw
material for one of the oldest whiskey
brands in the country but when they
added a young transplant from upstate
New York to the mix the result was a
perfect blend once a year whiskey
advocate bestows the highest honor in
the business whisk abacus 2019 whiskey
of the year is George Dickel 13 year old
bottle and bond their latest winner this
mesmerizing concoction from 35 year-old
Nicole Austin I knew our whiskey's are
amazing and bond and bond is just it's
the strongest statement you can make
that this is our whiskey we made it and
it's fantastic bottled in bond is old
but new again the style of spirit traces
back to 1897 when Congress passed a law
trying to discourage counterfeit alcohol
to be bottled in bond a liquor has to be
at least four years old 100 proof and
the product of one distillery at one
location in one season it lets a
consumer know the producer had their
hand in the product every step of the
way this is all whiskey that's in here
for anywhere between could be some of
these are as old as 16 years old you
know I wanted people to know that kind
of my era would be all about
authenticity and quality and
transparency and bottom bond is the best
proxy we have in American spirits Nicole
Austin's degree is in chemical engine
but she was still searching for ways to
make that a career when she walked into
a Brooklyn bar out of college the
whiskey she was served changed
everything it's amazing how many people
have those light bulb moments around
really great wine or spirits or
something that just like sets you off
I said considered it before like no one
had said also you could do this as a job
after first working at Kings County
distillery in Brooklyn Austin spent a
year and a half in Ireland until she was
hired in 2018 by liqueur giant Diageo to
run the newly renamed Cascade Hollow
distillery in Tullahoma her name is now
painted in big bold letters outside it's
not embarrassing it's your name general
manager and distiller my mother's very
proud you think we've always been like a
little bit of a sleeper because in
Tennessee it's Jack Daniels like the
giant monolith yeah and everything else
is like I think people thought Tennessee
whiskey was somehow different than
bourbon Tennessee whiskey is bourbon it
just has to be made in Tennessee and
filtered through charcoal before it's
aged
that we actually burn on site it comes
from sugar maple so this is what goes in
how much do you think about the fact
that you don't look like the old time
picture of somebody making Tennessee
whiskey in 1880
I mean that was always a fantasy anyways
there's always been women in this
industry since the beginning
they just weren't the face on the bottle
and you're comfortable in that role no
not really
no but it's important so it's like a
very rich funky Raj just it actually
won't become whiskey technically in
class there goes
there's a straight booze
don't drink it
Wow making whiskey is not complicated
take grain ferment it distill it and let
it age but making great whiskey takes an
additional step blending and Austin has
become a savant
each of these whiskies went into the
barrel of the exact same way and that's
the mystery of maturation and whiskey
but we don't know exactly why that one
smells like vanilla and why that one
smells more like fruit that's my job as
a blender to find them at just the right
time in their maturation when they're at
their peak and blend those flavors
together so that the sum of their parts
is greater than the individual after
Austin's first creation at George Dickel
one whiskey of the year she's been hard
at work trying to make a version that is
even better how much have you thought
about how to follow that up yeah no
pressure like your first at-bat in the
majors you hit a home run what do you do
after that
yeah right I guess so that's the hope I
want this distillery to grow I want
people to know about this place and it's
whiskey I want them to share my passion
this is the only way to do that there
you go Oh Dana my lord what do you I see
that we're missing some here but Dana
has some in the middle
Michele already drank hers apparently
delicious yeah guys it was gone Wow okay
we'll have to send some more over it was
it was so much fun hanging out with with
Nicole I mean she's just she's just
she's fun to hang out with to begin with
but it's really fast that he tapping
into her knowledge and and what she's
been able to curate and create at George
Dickel and bottled and bond
yeah recognition hasn't and she's
getting it a lot of other women are too
well if you've been checking out what's
behind me right now